doctor strange is coming back it is
conspiracy theorists are out there
there's a lot that they think yeah
they're saying maybe
he's evil
part of the illuminati
i'm just trying to pull faces as clues
that will then be churned over on the
internet
no i like yeah maybe who knows who knows
i do
i know you know it's the beginning of
all of this isn't it and it's weird i i
kind of escaped with spiderman because
we were doing reshoots for strange i
couldn't do the tour so poor tom and z
and jacob and everyone else had to go
yeah uh no i no yeah no i haven't heard
about that i mean yeah and just sort of
deny everything okay so i'm i'm gonna
start doing that same game again
listen i will tell you this it is it's a
feast it's a sam rainey special and it's
uh it's got everything it says in the
title and a lot more besides
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have to
talk about doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness a lot of news
today including a new doctor strange
variant another new character who looks
to be wong's girlfriend and of course we
have to talk about the cameos coming in
multiverse of madness as we just heard
benedict cumberbatch say
it's gonna be a feast so let's dive
right in but of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest marvel news so
marvel studios has released some funko
pops for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness some of them are
what you expect but some of them are new
and really really cool and two of them
actually reveal new characters coming in
multiverse of madness that we weren't
aware of before kind of one was actually
hinted at in the trailer but we didn't
really know what to make of it until now
now from what i've been told about the
movie multiverse of madness really is
going to live up to its name on both
parts meaning multiverse and then
madness and like you just heard benedict
cumberbatch say it's going to be a feast
it's going to live up to its name and
more this means we are going to be
getting a ton of cameos and in case you
missed it yesterday patrick stewart did
confirm that that is indeed him in the
multiverse of madness trailer who's dr
strange so big cameos coming and
variants and these funko pops reveal a
new variant of dr strange the one that
we were expecting but perhaps not
exactly the same the funko pops have
revealed a strange supreme funko pop
which means there's going to be a
strange supreme in multiverse of madness
now originally we thought that perhaps
this evil version of doctor strange that
we see in the trailer could have been
strange supreme from marvel's what if
animated series however i really don't
think that that's the case and i don't
think that this strange supreme is going
to be the one from what if as well we've
actually seen the supreme strange in the
trailer or at least a statue of him i'm
sure most of you remember the scene
where wanda says to steven you break the
rules and become a hero i do it and i
become the enemy well when she says you
break the rules and become a hero it
shows our doctor strange from our
universe looking at a statue of a
variant of himself a different doctor
strange now if we look at the clothes
that are on this statue they actually
match what this doctor strange is
wearing in the funko supreme strange and
the way that this trailer makes it seem
makes it seem like this supreme strange
was at one point in time a hero now i
don't think that strange supreme is
actually alive typically they dedicate
statues to people when they die however
i do believe that he is of course going
to be in the movie otherwise why would
they make a funko of him which leads me
to believe that supreme strange is the
one that's trying to help our doctor
strange or at the very least he's the
one that's trying to keep the multiverse
together he's trying to keep it in peace
and prevent a multiversal war he might
even be the one that is in charge of the
illuminati or at least a part of the
council now we know that the scarlet
witch is going to attack the illuminati
at the illuminati's headquarters that
could be where she kills dr strange not
ours but strange supreme and this might
be where things really go into madness
because if there is a string supreme he
is probably the most powerful doctor
strange and if he was a part of the
illuminati that means he was definitely
helping the multiverse trying to keep it
all in order and if he's gone there's a
good chance that it might fall apart but
that's where our doctor strange comes in
that's where it's time for him to step
up now of course this supreme strange
could have died at an earlier time and
our doctor strange could simply find
himself in the universe where the
supreme strange once was and he finds
out that he was viewed as a hero and he
was a really good guy however while this
is definitely possible why would they
make a funko pop of somebody who's not
gonna really be in the movie i wouldn't
put it past them but i am guessing that
strange supreme is going to play at
least somewhat of a significant part in
this movie to get his own funko so as of
right now i believe we have four
variants of doctor strange in the movie
we have our doctor strange we have
defender strange who does get his own
funko so we get a little bit of a better
look at him we have the evil doctor
strange who we kind of got a funko for
it just labels him as doctor strange but
it is a limited chase edition so that's
pretty cool and then of course we have
this new one strange supreme and i bet
yeah there's a lot more variants of
doctor strange coming again multiverse
of madness so let's dive into that
madness and dive into those cameos but
first we have been introduced to a new
character via these funko pops as well
and her name is sarah and as you can see
sarah is wearing sorcerer robes now this
could be sarah wolfe and if it is marvel
is doing a little bit of a twist on this
but in the comics sarah is wong's
girlfriend could she be a sorcerer in
the movie absolutely that makes perfect
sense after all that's who wang hangs
around all the time sorcerers however
this could be sarah crowler who is a
very powerful magician in marvel comics
and in various comics she's actually
depicted as baron mordo's mother is this
going to be the mother of baron mordo i
don't think so however i wouldn't rule
out it being a variant of baron mordo
after all we have seen a variant of loki
that is female of course sylvie so if
this is a variant of mordo simply a
female variant they could just go by the
name sarah but i'm hoping that it's
wong's girlfriend because i think he
deserves that now as far as cameos are
concerned there have been a lot of
rumors going around about what we could
get and here's the thing we've been
hearing about deadpool we've been
hearing about wolverine tom cruise as
iron man the really cool thing about all
of this is that any and all of this
could be true if this movie really is
over the top and truly madness then you
can expect a lot of different cameos and
why not throw ryan reynolds in there why
not throw tom cruise in there john
krasinski as mr fantastic chris evans
but not as captain america as the human
torch from the fantastic four anything
is possible and it sounds like marvel's
gotten pretty creative with multiverse
of madness and even recently bruce campo
confirmed that he is also in multiverse
of madness in a recent interview he said
the deal with doctor strange is
interesting a majority of the film was
re-shot extensively so i have no idea
what's in there and what isn't i did a
cool scene with a character that's been
beloved for years and we'll have to see
what ends up in the movie i don't know
if it's still in there it's a pretty
cool part now a majority of the people
seem to think that this beloved
character is professor xavier which
would mean that bruce campbell is a part
of the illuminati most likely could he
be playing somebody like balder the
brave or could he be playing somebody
like mephisto or c'thun again anything
is possible and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness truly is going to
be a crazy film hopefully we just see a
ton of different cameos used in a very
good way wolverine no matter who the
actor is more x-men some of the
fantastic four new and old and probably
a lot of people that we won't really
expect to see in the movie that surprise
us but let me know what you think about
all of this in the comments down below
what do you think about strange supreme
and who do you think sarah is also
comment which cameo you would like to
see the most in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me